Buenas noches, a todos. Bienvenidos a la clase Master de Tradestation.
Hoy es nuestra serie de elementos de estrategia,
donde highlight ciertas herramientas en la plataforma de Tradestation
que te permiten backtestar estrategias,
automatizar la ejecución,
y algunas de las herramientas de estrategia más avanzadas,
como el Portfolio Maestro.
El Portfolio Maestro es el highlight de la presentación de hoy,
y lo vamos a hablar en un momento.
Antes de hacerlo,
vamos a hacer algunas introducciones y disclosiones.
Mi nombre es Jesús Nava.
Soy el director de la entrenamiento de clientes
y educación para Tradestation.
Cada simple idea que hablo en esta presentación
es para propósitos educativos,
y no es una recomendación de Tradestation.
Además, que la tradición activa no es suelta para todos,
y que la performance histórica no garantiza resultados futuros.
Muchas gracias a todos por tomar tiempo a través de vuestros schedules
y por estar aquí y por unirme a esta presentación.
No tengo un download de PDF o PowerPoint hoy.
Pensé que solo concentráramos en la herramienta,
ir ahí directamente,
y destacar algunas de sus funcionalidades.
Así que déjame ir adelante y hacer eso.
Voy a cambiar a mi plataforma de Tradestation
y hablar un poco sobre el Portfolio Maestro
desde una base conceptual.
La razón por la que la Tradestation
se invirtió en una pieza de software como el Portfolio Maestro
es para permitir que testes estrategias de tradición
en un Portfolio de símbolos.
Por lo tanto, el nombre.
La idea aquí no solo fue retestar en símbolos individuos,
como una análisis de trato que te permite hacer.
Aquí tengo un contrato futuro,
un símbolo continuo en ES.
Puedo aplicar una estrategia para agregar ES
y mirar el reporte de la estrategia de la performance.
Pero entonces la pregunta es,
¿cómo performará la estrategia
si la aplico a un producto diferente,
a diferentes futuras, a un producto diferente?
Ese tipo de cosa es lo que el Portfolio Maestro te permite hacer.
Porque no solo te permite tomar una estrategia
y aplicarla para coger un grupo de símbolos,
pero también te permite ver un reporte de la performance
en todos los símbolos tradidos
como si hubieras tradido la estrategia en todos esos símbolos
y darte un reporte overall sobre cómo lo hicieron.
Y te permite hacer un comparado muy rápido
y contrasto entre los símbolos que han sido tradidos.
Así que esto es lo que muchos tradidores de estrategia hacen.
No solo desarrollan una estrategia,
pero también aplican a un grupo de símbolos
para asegurar que la estrategia se mantenga consistente
y que provee una performance similar a la de un portfolio.
Así que vamos a empezar y vamos a App y abrimos el Portfolio Maestro.
Vamos a ir adelante y establecemos nuestro Portfolio Maestro
para hacer un backtest.
Una de las primeras cosas que voy a mostrarles hoy es el ranking
y cómo rankar símbolos en un portfolio.
Ranking a veces se convierte en importante
considerando que no todos tienen capital ilimitado para traducir.
Así que tienes que hacer una decisión sobre
cuáles símbolos van a ser los candidatos de la tradición en tu portfolio.
Por ejemplo, si aplicas esta estrategia sobre una lista de símbolos,
digamos, 10 símbolos o 30 símbolos, o lo que sea el número de símbolos,
y solo tienes una cantidad ilimitada de capital,
como $5,000 o $10,000.
Así que solo puedes invertir en tantos símbolos.
Entonces, de los 10 o 30 símbolos que tienes en tu portfolio,
tienes un mecanismo para decir
cuáles símbolos son los que merecen tu inversión
basado en un ranking particular.
Así que vas a rancar el símbolo basado en un métrico particular
y luego aplicar la estrategia a los que tienen
la mejor performance basada en ese métrico.
Así que eso es exactamente lo que vamos a hacer hoy.
Así que voy a diseñar, no tengo un grupo de estrategia ahora.
Voy a hacer algo muy simple para que puedas ver cómo
estas estrategias de ranking realmente afectan
la forma en que la estrategia está traducida.
Voy a crear un grupo de estrategia.
Así que déjame ir y clicar en nuevo aquí.
Bien, vamos a llamar a este ranking.
Bien, voy a usar ranking y money management en un lugar.
Bien, estoy usando ranking y money management en un lugar
porque esos son los dos tabs que ves aquí en el very top
cuando estás creando tu grupo de estrategia.
Así que quiero solo conectar los dos
porque sé que estoy creando un ejemplo para ambos.
Y voy a usar equities para este ejemplo.
Bien, voy a agregar una estrategia.
Voy a usar algo custom.
Custom significa que existe en tu lista de estrategias
con el nombre custom.
No es algo que no tengas.
Así que vayas a tu lista de estrategias
y vas a encontrar una estrategia llamada custom strategy long entry.
Y voy a usar una estrategia custom
porque quiero una simple regla que todos podamos entender
y ver cómo el ranking y money management
afectan los símbolos que están traducidos.
Voy a seleccionarlo y clicar OK.
Está ahí en la parte de arriba,
o al menos aquí en la parte de arriba de mi Portfolio Maestro.
Puedo ver los impuestos que son default en esta estrategia particular.
No estoy seguro de si puedes leer ese texto negro en el amarillo,
pero dice LE Condición equals C greater than O.
C greater than O es Closed greater than Open.
Así que esta estrategia o esta estrategia custom es una simple regla.
Si el Open es menos que el precio de la cerradura,
entonces generará una entrada larga.
Esa idea es muy simple,
pero voy a cambiar eso a algo diferente.
Así que déjame ir a mi estrategia group settings,
aquí en la parte de arriba.
Clicco en impuestos de estrategia
y voy a cambiar los impuestos de esa estrategia
a Closed greater than Zero.
Así que simplemente simplificamos la regla
y no estamos realmente mirando o comparando los precios de la actual cerradura.
Estoy buscando cualquier precio que sea mayor que cero.
Así que si algún negocio trae a un precio mayor que cero,
entonces esa es la condición que va a trigger la entrada larga.
Técnicamente cada símbolo en el que la estrategia se aplica va a traer,
porque van a traer a un precio que sea mayor que cero.
Así que esa va a ser mi estrategia.
Nada extraño.
Recuerda que hoy estamos solo concentrando
en la parte de arriba de la estrategia
y vamos a ver su aplicación mejor si simplificamos la entrada.
Así que déjame ir a agregar símbolos a mi estrategia group.
Así que voy a ir a la lista de símbolos,
agregar símbolos y vamos a ver.
Voy a ir aquí a la lista de símbolos de Tradestation Customs
y tengo una lista de símbolos aquí
que está hecha de 10 símbolos.
Los vemos aquí en la lista,
empezando con Disney y hasta American Express.
Esto es algo que he creado anterior.
Puedes crear listas de símbolos customes en tu sitio también.
De nuevo, esto es solo para demostrar
cómo estos 10 símbolos van a ser afectados
por la estrategia de rango y manejo de dinero que voy a aplicar.
Voy a clicar OK y los símbolos se van a agregar aquí
a mi estrategia group.
Puedo verlos ahí.
Y a este punto, luego,
voy a la tab de rango y especifico
cómo es que quiero arreglar los símbolos y traerlos.
Pero para que veamos la diferencia,
déjame ir adelante y correr el backtest de los portfolios
sin ninguna estrategia de rango
para que luego podamos ver las posiciones de nuevo
y ver lo que cambió.
Voy a venir aquí a Manage Portfolios
y voy a crear un nuevo portfólio
que se llamará Ranking and Money Management.
Y dentro de este portfólio,
vamos a agregar la estrategia group que he creado
que tiene el mismo nombre, Ranking and Money Management.
Y, por supuesto, puedes ver los elementos de esa grupo
que tiene la estrategia custom que hemos modificado
y el símbolo 10 símbolos que hemos añadido.
De este punto, voy a ir aquí a Backtest Portfolio.
Antes de que lo haga,
vamos a ir a ver algunos posiciones de portfólio.
No tengo que cambiar aquí,
no tengo que cambiar nada aquí en general.
Tenemos una tab para constrangos y una para Portfolio Stops,
que vamos a llegar a en un momento.
Entonces, nada que cambiar aquí todavía.
Voy a cancelar esto y luego hacer el backtest.
Esto trae a este diálogo,
permitiendo cambiar lo que es la capital inicial,
lo que va a usar el diálogo para el backtest.
En este ejemplo,
estoy backtesting dos años de datos
para cada uno de esos 10 símbolos que tengo en mi lista de símbolos.
El tipo de backtest es estándar.
Voy a mantener todo símbolo
y voy a hacer clic en Perform Backtest.
Ahí vamos.
Se terminó de hacer el backtest de esos 10 símbolos.
Voy a hacer clic en View Report ahora.
Y para resumir, para aquellos que están con nosotros,
por ahora,
Portfolio Maestro es una herramienta
que es parte del software de TradeStation
y te permite backtest el Portfolio de símbolos.
Entonces puedes seleccionar una estrategia.
Puede ser una de las que vienen construidas en TradeStation
o una que crees tú mismo
y aplica a un Portfolio de símbolos
para ver cómo se performan en todo el Portfolio.
Así que aquí tengo el reporte de la performance para este backtest.
Puedes ver que es una estrategia perdida.
Los 17,000 dólares de perdida.
Entonces queremos saber qué fue traducido.
Vamos aquí a la lista de trade
y veamos algunas de las informaciones aquí.
Déjame ver si puedo...
Tengo que hacer clic en cada una.
Bien, está bien.
Entonces puedes ver que esta es la información
que quería ver en este particular backtest.
Bien.
Así que sabemos que la estrategia
va de dos años desde hoy.
Entonces el primer día que ves aquí,
el 22 de diciembre de 2021,
es el primer día que la estrategia
puede poner en una transacción.
Recuerda que hay algo en una estrategia backtest
y si has hecho estrategia backtest,
sabes que hay algo como el back de tu mano,
que hay algo llamado MaxBarsBackSetting.
MaxBarsBack es solo un grupo de barras,
estoy hablando de barras históricas de precio,
que están setas o reservadas
para las calculaciones de la estrategia.
La estrategia usa un default de 50.
Entonces los primeros 50 barras
en este histórico backtest
están reservados para las calculaciones.
Eso explica por qué el día no es octubre 10.
Hoy es octubre 10, ¿verdad?
Eso explica por qué el día no es octubre 10 de 2021,
es el 22 de diciembre de 2021,
porque los primeros 50 barras
están reservados para las calculaciones de la estrategia.
Pero en adición a eso,
puedes ver que el segundo rango
tiene un día de 10 de 9 de 2023.
Entonces el backtest histórico
que estamos realizando aquí
usa barras cerradas,
que significa que la actividad de trading de hoy,
que todavía está siendo construida como una barra diaria,
no está incluida en esta actividad de backtest.
Entonces es claro que no sólo vemos
cuándo la venta fue ingresada,
sino que también vemos lo que la parada de esa venta es
como la cerradura de ayer.
Y te dice que estás abierta
en esta particular posición de Disney.
Y esto es la ganancia y la pérdida
que estás haciendo en esa posición.
Entonces, desde la ingresada en 22 de diciembre de 2021,
estamos abajo de $6,500.
Pero es interesante aquí
que todas las ventas que fueron ingresadas,
empezando aquí con el rango número uno, Disney,
Home Depot, Johnson & Johnson,
Walmart, Intel, Microsoft, Apple, Cisco y American Express,
todas fueron ingresadas en el mismo día,
22 de diciembre de 2021.
Y la razón por eso es porque,
si ustedes recuerdan la regla de mi estrategia,
dije que si algún símbolo está ingresando más que cero,
traiganlo.
Y son todas las ventas que están aquí
porque la estrategia solo tomará una venta
en una dirección al mismo tiempo,
lo que significa que una vez que traiga largo,
una vez que estableces una posición larga,
no hará nada diferente
hasta que haya una salida
o la estrategia haga algo más.
En este caso,
solo tenemos un único símbolo,
que es la clave más grande que cero,
y no tenemos ninguna salida.
Así que eso es todo lo que la estrategia fue capaz de hacer.
Fue capaz de establecer posiciones
para estos 10 símbolos
en el 22 de diciembre de 2021.
Pero puedes ver que trae los símbolos,
no tiene tiempo aquí.
Así que podemos,
podemos teóricamente decir que
los tomó en la orden que están disponibles
en la lista de símbolos.
Así que si voy a volver a,
a ver,
voy a volver a mi portfólio
y si abro mi lista de símbolos,
va en esta orden que los símbolos son
Disney, HD, Johnson & Johnson.
Voy a volver al reporte.
Así que puedes ver que Disney, HD, Johnson & Johnson.
Así que esa es la orden que pide,
la forma en la que los símbolos están listados
en tu lista de símbolos customes.
Esto es una lista de símbolos customes.
Así que cualquier orden que veas los símbolos,
esa es la forma en la que la estrategia
se va a acercar a ellos y traerlos.
Así que vamos a hablar de el rango y modificar,
¿sabes?
Cuáles símbolos van a ser traídos primero.
Voy a venir aquí a mi portfólio.
Bien.
Y no lo hacemos a este nivel.
No lo hacemos a nivel de portfólio,
el rango está hecho a nivel de estrategia de grupo.
Voy a ir al grupo de estrategia,
selecciono mi rango y el manejo de dinero aquí abajo.
Voy a ir al tablo de rango y pedir a la estrategia
para marcar mis símbolos basados en...
A ver.
Muchos de estos son basados en indicadores técnicos.
Así que vamos a marcarlos por el cambio de porcentaje.
Si selecciono el cambio de porcentaje,
esta ventana abre y me permite especificar,
¿cuál es el cambio de porcentaje en mi libro de rango?
Primero, voy a hacer el método de filtro.
Voy a seleccionar los símbolos de rango superior.
Límite de filtro.
Este es el número de símbolos que
quieres que el rango regrese.
Así que en este caso voy a ponerlo a 1.
Intervol de rango y intervalo de calculación son interesantes
porque el intervalo de calculación es como el timeframe
del gráfico que está utilizado para la calculación de cambio de porcentaje.
Mientras el intervalo de rango es cómo a veces el rango va a suceder.
Puedo poner el rango a la semana
para que cada semana tengamos un nuevo rango.
Así que esto es lo que estoy intentando decir.
Calcula el cambio de porcentaje.
Mira por el símbolo superior basado en mi límite de filtro
y rango los símbolos en una base diaria.
Y el rango es basado en el cambio de porcentaje basado en el timeframe diario.
Veando hacia atrás 30 días.
Esto es donde el verano es especificado.
Así que voy a calcular un 30 día de negociación,
cambio de porcentaje,
rango los símbolos basado en ese cambio de porcentaje,
y luego negociar el símbolo superior.
Vamos a decir que hay otro filtro o otro input aquí que dice
que el mínimo precio requerido para una negociación debe ser tomado.
Tengo 1.5.
Así que significa que cualquier símbolo que esté negociando debajo de $1.50 no va a ser negociado.
Puedes setar ese tipo de filtros si quieres.
Si tienes una lista más grande de símbolos,
estoy seguro de que los 10 símbolos que he seleccionado
están todos negociando por encima de $1.50.
Así que el rango de alto a bajo es defaultado a verdad.
Esa es la forma en la que lo quería.
Y el límite de rango si quieres setar algunos límites
basado en cómo estás encargando los símbolos.
Eso es algo que puedes hacer también.
Así que voy a dejar los otros sitios como están.
Y voy a...
Una vez que lo vuelvo, noté algo muy interesante.
Una vez que lo vuelvo, si voy aquí a mi portfólio
y voy a mi portfólio de rango y de dinero,
mi estrategia de rango, el que acabo de destacar en rojo,
ha sido añadido.
Así que una vez que haces esa edición o ese cambio
a nivel de grupo de estrategia,
entonces verás esa estrategia aplicada aquí
en mi portfólio, mi estero.
Bien.
Puedo abrirlo y ver algunos de los impuestos
para esa estrategia de rango.
Y voy a ir aquí y retestar el portfólio.
Los mismos sitios.
No estoy cambiando nada.
Solo quiero ver cómo el retesto cambia
y algunos de los valores que son diferentes.
Así que vamos al reporte.
Primero, en el sumario,
puedes ver que tuvimos un cambio en la profitability
de esta estrategia.
Todavía es una estrategia que se está perdiendo,
pero se está perdiendo menos que lo que estaba haciendo antes.
Lo que estoy más interesado en es la lista de intercambios.
Bien.
Entonces, empezando aquí en el very top,
tenemos...
Voy a abrir esto un poco más.
Bien.
Entonces, empezando aquí en el very top,
ahora puedes ver que Disney
no es el primer símbolo que se ha traducido.
Eso es muy claro ahora.
El primer símbolo que se ha traducido es Apple
basado en este rango de cambio de porcentaje.
Y ese es el símbolo que se ha traducido en diciembre 22.
Mi segunda ventaja no sucedió hasta el 4 de enero.
Recuerda que cuando hicimos el reporte de la performance al principio,
cada ventaja se ha traducido en diciembre 22
porque estábamos buscando un símbolo de traducción muy simple,
que es más cerca del cero.
Entonces, cada símbolo se ha traducido en diciembre 22.
Ahora, las cosas han cambiado
porque nos contaron la estrategia de backtest.
Espera.
Toma los 10 símbolos, calcula el cambio de porcentaje,
ranga los símbolos basados en este cálculo de cambio de porcentaje
y solo trate el símbolo del top.
Y esa es la razón por la que, en diciembre 22,
estamos solo tratando Apple.
Fernando está preguntando si puede isolar cada símbolo en la lista de traducción
para que pueda comparar P&L para cada uno.
Sí, por supuesto que puede.
Este es un reporte combinado, si vas al sumario.
Entonces, toda la performance de todos los 10 símbolos
me ha dado una pérdida de $4,000.
Pero si voy al análisis de la traducción
y voy aquí a este pequeño botón en la derecha de la derecha de la pantalla
para ver si escondes,
puedo seleccionar todos los símbolos
y luego ver cómo cada símbolo contribuyó a esa pérdida.
Como puedes ver, de todas estas columnas,
solo hay tres símbolos que me han dado resultados positivos.
Apple, Walmart y Microsoft.
Todos los otros símbolos me han dado resultados negativos,
pero todas combinadas,
puedo verlo en esta columna aquí,
que es el total de porcentaje.
Entonces, el rango es una cosa.
Deja que veas las otras estrategias de rango que están ahí.
Voy a volver aquí a mi grupo de estrategias.
Algunos de los otros rango disponibles aquí son los valores RSI.
Puedes rango por Williams R.
Perfección de retorno.
Eso es interesante, ¿verdad?
Se ve en el retorno de cada símbolo y los rango a base de eso.
Pero juega con la funcionalidad
y vea cómo afecta la lista de símbolos.
En el lado de la gestión de dinero,
déjame ir aquí y agregar algo como...
Esto es más de una tamaña de negocio.
Por default, está utilizando una cantidad fijada.
Entonces, incluso si no hago una estrategia de gestión de dinero,
si voy de vuelta a mi reporte,
probablemente notas que cada símbolo,
déjame ir aquí a mi lista de negocios,
si miras la columna de la cantidad,
cada símbolo está traicionando 100 símbolos.
Si traes 100 símbolos de Apple,
traicionando a $173,
eso es un inversión de $17,000.
Mientras, si traes 100 símbolos de Cisco,
traicionando a $62,
eso es solo un inversión de $6,000.
Entonces estamos hablando de ampliar la cantidad de inversión
si estuvieras a traicionar a Apple.
Entonces, el riesgo involucrado en traer una seguridad
va a ser diferente de la otra
si tu cantidad siempre es una cantidad fijada.
Entonces, usando una estrategia de gestión de dinero
que cambia tu cantidad
basada en cualquier métrica que usas,
puedes igualizar tus posiciones
para que puedas tener un riesgo balanceado
por todas tus posiciones.
Puedo elegir algo como, por ejemplo,
una cantidad fijada por precio
por cantidad.
Y si hago una cantidad fijada por precio,
entonces puedo decir
el valor de la dólar que quiero invertir
en cada una de esas posiciones.
La cantidad máxima, 5000 símbolos,
y alrededor de la más cerca de uno símbolo.
Si utilizo este métrico,
que es la cantidad fijada por precio,
me voy a volver a mi portfólio
y ahora, en adición a mi rango de cambio de porcentaje,
que es mi estrategia de rango,
también tengo mi manejo de dinero
fijado por precio.
Ahora, déjame hacer el test de vuelta ahora
y ver cómo afecta la cantidad
de cada una de las posiciones que están allí.
Voy a ver el reporte
y en mi lista de intercambios,
puedes ver los intercambios.
Puedes ver que sólo intercambió 57 puertas de Apple
en comparación con 158 puertas
que intercambiaron por Cisco,
porque ahora está tomando un vistazo
al precio de la seguridad
y calculando, ¿sabes?
¿Cuánto tendría que invertir $10,000
en cada una de estas simbolas?
Entonces es muy interesante cómo puedes manejar
tu tamaño de intercambio de esta manera también.
Voy a ir a mis estrategias.
Vamos a ver y esto es el manejo de dinero.
Vamos a hacer FIXED FRACTIONAL
con ATR RISK.
Ahora, esto utiliza ATR,
que es un concepto muy interesante, ¿sabes?
El modo en el que lo hicimos antes,
lo hicimos por el precio de la seguridad.
Entonces, lo que sea el precio de la seguridad es
que hemos especificado una cantidad de dinero
que queríamos invertir
y automáticamente calculó
el número de puertas que trajeron.
Aquí está mirando a ATR
y ATR es visto como riesgo.
Entonces, lo más alto el valor de ATR
significa que la seguridad está moviendo más,
es un poco más volátil.
Entonces, va a usar eso y va a
reducir el número de puertas traídas
por esa posición.
Por supuesto,
vas a tener una oportunidad aquí para decir,
OK, ¿qué es el riesgo de porcentaje?
Esto es 5% de la equidad.
Entonces, sabemos que el punto de comienzo
en cualquier estrategia es 100,000 dólares.
Puedes cambiar eso.
Eso es solo el punto de comienzo de cualquier estrategia.
Entonces, cuando hablamos de 5% de riesgo de la equidad,
estamos hablando de ese punto de comienzo inicial.
Cualquier ganancias que haces después de eso
van a ser añadidas a tu equidad
y luego tu riesgo va a ser calculado
mejor a base de eso.
Y encuentras esa posición
cuando realizas el backtest.
Te lo mostraré en un momento.
Pero aquí tenemos el 5% de riesgo de la equidad.
Tenemos el multiplicador de ATR.
Vamos a setar esto a 10.
Multiplica porque usa el factor.
Primero calcula lo que es el valor de ATR.
Vamos a decir que, para Apple,
el ATR es $2.50.
Si yo seto el multiplicador a 10,
va a multiplicar esos $2.50 por 10,
diciéndome un número numeric de 25.
Y va a usar ese número para afectar
el ratio de riesgos que estoy tratando para Apple.
Vamos a hacer algunas modificaciones aquí
y puedes ver ese efecto.
El ATR es 10.
Y, de nuevo, tienes una forma de especificar
el máximo número de riesgos
y cómo rondarlo hacia abajo o hacia arriba.
Vamos a hacer el backtest.
Vamos aquí a mi portfólio.
De nuevo, estoy mirando lo que he añadido aquí
a mi backtest.
Y puedes ver que la estrategia de manejo de dinero
ha sido cambiada a una fracción fixada con el riesgo de ATR.
Y aquí dice que compras 10 veces el ATR
por 10 barras de mirada,
pero no más de 5,000 compras.
Riesgo de no más de 5% de la equidad.
Así que esto te da un poco más de información
sobre lo que va a hacer.
Hago el backtest.
Por cierto, aquí es donde cambias el capital inicial.
Mira.
$100,000.
Si no suena a lo que es el balance de tu cuenta,
entonces tendrás que modificarlo aquí.
Así que la calculación de la cantidad de intercambios
se haga correctamente o basada en lo que es realista en tu lado.
$100,000 es mi punto de comienzo.
Voy a hacer el backtest.
Voy a ver el reporte.
Y puedes ver los tamaños que están intercambiados.
Se intercambiaron 91 compras de Apple y 537 compras de Cisco.
Recuerda que esto es tomar un vistazo a ATR
y hacer esa decisión.
Si recuerdas, cuando estábamos haciendo
una cantidad directa de inversión,
vimos que las compras de Apple y de Cisco
no estaban tan lejos.
Creo que intercambiaron unos 50 compras de Apple
y unos 150 compras de Cisco.
Así que es tal vez triple la cantidad,
doble o triple la cantidad.
Pero mira la diferencia ahora.
Solo intercambiaron 91 compras de Apple y 537 compras de Cisco.
Ahora estamos hablando de cinco veces la cantidad
de compras de Cisco cuando se comparan con Apple.
La razón por eso es porque
quizás Apple tiene un valor más alto de ATR que Cisco.
Los movimientos de Cisco no van a compararse con Apple
y ese tipo de calculación toma en cuenta ese riesgo.
El riesgo, el más movimiento la seguridad tiene,
el riesgo es considerado,
y el menos compras,
la estrategia va a invertir en ese tratado particular.
Es un concepto interesante, ¿verdad?
Vamos a volver a mi portfólio,
vamos a mi grupo de estrategia una vez más.
Usé el multiplicador de 10.
Si elegí un multiplicador diferente,
o incluso si reducí el riesgo aquí,
digamos que haga un riesgo de 1%
y voy a usar un multiplicador de 5.
Entonces voy aquí a mi portfólio.
Puedes ver que refleja, ¿dónde está?
Voy a abrir la gestión de dinero.
Puedo ver que los cambios se reflejan.
Y todo lo que necesito es volver al portfólio una vez más.
Ahí vamos, voy al reporte y puedes ver la cantidad de compras aquí.
Ahora puedes ver que es un poco más alto ahora.
Ahora estamos hablando de siete veces,
o seis o siete veces la cantidad.
Pero, de nuevo, es todo basado en ATR
y en lo que la calculación de ATR y el multiplicador que estás especificando.
Hasta ahora hemos hablado de dos cosas que puedes hacer a tu
test de vuelta o tu test de vuelta de tu portfólio para cambiar cosas.
Hablamos de la rango,
la forma de cambiar los símbolos y decidir cuáles son los tratados primero.
Y también el manejo de dinero,
lo que significa que estás afectando el tamaño de los tratados
y algunas de esas otras componentes.
Vamos a hablar de las constracciones y parámetros de nivel de portfólio.
Pero vamos a ir y a ver una pregunta aquí.
Fernandez está preguntando si puede hacer una optimización para el mismo listo de símbolos
y también mostrar los resultados de PNL por símbolo para cada iteración.
Definitivamente, sí, puede.
Cuando haces, déjame mostrarles muy rápido,
cuando haces el test de vuelta y vienes aquí para el tipo de test de vuelta,
puedes ponerlo en un tipo de test de vuelta optimizado que te permite hacer una optimización
en todos los símbolos listados y ver la performance individual de cada uno de los símbolos.
Voy a cancelar esto.
Todos los constracciones y parámetros de nivel de portfólio van a estar aquí en el lado de la portfólio.
El ranking y el manejo del dinero están en el grupo de estrategia.
Tienes esos dos tabs, pero todos los constracciones y parámetros de nivel de portfólio
van a estar aquí en el portfólio de manejo.
Entonces, aquí, voy a ir a settings de portfólio y tienes constracciones y parámetros de portfólio.
Vamos a suponer que queremos hacer un parámetro de portfólio.
Voy a elegir el parámetro de portfólio.
Esto es un true.
El periodo aquí, tienes que poner un, dos, o tres por día.
Eso es solo la cantidad que estás perdiendo por un periodo particular,
o un mes, una semana, o un mes.
Vamos a ver qué hace esto.
Entonces, 2 significa que un 2% del portfólio se cae.
Entonces, si el portfólio se cae 2%, cerramos todas las posiciones hasta la siguiente semana.
Entonces, eso es donde el periodo cae.
Entonces, cerramos todo hasta la siguiente semana.
Si queremos cerrar todo hasta el próximo mes, entonces cambiamos este número a 1.
Vamos a ver si eso cae.
Vamos a ir y poner el parámetro.
Bien.
Y voy a clicar OK.
Y está listo aquí en el fondo.
Portfólio, parámetro.
Me voy a retestar el portfólio y ver si hay alguna vez que el portfólio se cae.
Voy a ver el report.
Bien.
Y voy a abrir mi nombre de señal porque puedes claramente ver que en diciembre 22
tuvimos nuestra primera venta por Apple.
Aún tengo mi estrategia de rango en lugar, si lo notas, y el manejo de dinero.
Estoy usando todos ellos.
Pero puedes ver que en diciembre 22 a mayo 19 de 2022 es donde el portfólio se cae.
Pero no solo para ese símbolo.
Si tomas un vistazo a todos los símbolos, todos los símbolos, por supuesto,
son traídos a diferentes dates porque tenemos nuestro rango y el manejo de dinero en lugar.
Pero haz un vistazo a las salidas.
Todas las salidas se han hecho en diciembre 19, diciembre 19, diciembre 19.
Porque en diciembre 19 de 2022 fue el día en el que calculó tu parámetro y se realizó
que tu entero portfólio de símbolos, en este caso 10 símbolos, había perdido 2% de tu equidad,
al que punto todas las posiciones se cerraron.
Entonces no es hasta, veamos, aquí.
No es hasta el 12 de julio que he podido poner un trato de huevos nuevamente para, es eso correcto?
Así que 519, 519, 519, 519, 519.
Así que el siguiente trato, aquí lo es.
Así que estaba intentando encontrar, sabes, donde el siguiente trato sucedió.
Pero parece que al very beginning of the strategy back test,
it traded all these symbols that you see above my yellow highlight.
On May 19th it closed every single one and on May 24th it started trading again.
I'm sure that this 524 2022 is a Monday because remember that we told the stop
to close all positions and then wait until next week to trade again.
And it seems that's exactly what it did.
It lost the 2% on May 19th, closed all the positions and then it resumed trading on 524,
which I find very interesting.
And you know, for anybody that's trading a portfolio, these are the type of things
that you want to put into place.
You know, a lot of times, yeah, you're back testing a single security.
You're looking at the performance report.
But if you're trading multiple securities simultaneously,
as a trader you see them all as a whole.
So you're looking at the whole portfolio.
And sometimes if you've lost a certain amount of your capital,
then you're going to stop your trading and, you know, resume at a later time.
In addition to the stops, let me go back here to my portfolio.
So in addition to the stops, we also have the constraints, you know,
and this is some other limitations you can put into your back test.
Like let me show you an example.
Maximum number of open positions right here.
So you notice that when I looked at the back test just a moment ago,
I had six positions open.
If I want to put a limit to that and say,
I only want to have, you know, three positions at any given moment.
So this is my limit.
Maximum number of open positions.
If I click OK to this, did I add it?
No, it seems like it didn't.
Let me go back in there just to make sure that I added constraints.
Yeah, I didn't add it.
So maximum number of open positions.
I'm going to set this to three, not 310, three,
and apply constraint right here.
So for the stops and the constraints, you have to apply it and then click on OK.
Stop and I can see my portfolio constraint.
Let me go ahead and back test the portfolio one more time.
OK, and I'm going to view the report and looking at the trade list right here,
which we were looking at earlier.
This is where I have all my signals and constraints
and everything that I add to my strategy.
You can see that on 520, it closed those top three positions.
But if you notice, December 22nd was the first trade,
January 4th was the second trade,
and January 19th was the third trade.
It stopped trading right after that.
It wasn't until it closed on May 20th, all those three trades,
that it actually went to trade the next symbol.
Johnson & Johnson on May 24th.
So it's only keeping open three positions at a time.
So that's the type of constraints that you can also put in a portfolio back test.
So let's recap, OK?
Ranking allows you to rank the symbols based on a particular metric.
You decide which symbol is going to be traded first.
Remember that we said that if you have a list of symbols,
the symbols are going to be traded in that order
in which they appear on the list, which is arbitrary.
Sometimes it's alphabetical.
So if you want to put a little bit of calculation
on which symbols are traded first, then you have that ranking mechanism.
You also have the money management strategy,
which allows you to modify the trade size.
How much investment am I putting on?
What risk am I taking?
And you have different money management strategies there as well.
And then for my portfolio level type of strategy,
you have the constraint,
which limits the number of positions that you are trading,
like in this example,
and many other constraints that you can look at.
And also, you know, the portfolio stops.
So you can set up a stop that tracks all your positions performance.
And if there's a drop that meets a certain percentage,
it'll close all your open positions.
In addition to that stop or overall stop,
you also have access to a profit target
and a trailing stop if you want to use that as well.
This is it. This is my presentation.
All right. So, guys, thank you so much for joining me today.
Thank you for your support of the Trade Station Masterclass.
Have a wonderful afternoon.
And I hope to see you in a future class.
Great having you today. Goodbye, everyone.